the 18 year old male was sent to
hospital when he was sent us with oh he
is still conscious at the moment I
believe the doctors conducting
examination and Cureton a cure him at
the moment so I do not know the current
situation maybe the hospital and they
give you more information your second
questions are you be present our guest
at this moment and he was arrested for
something police officer will contact
further environment and then once after
the entire which we will decide whether
we will press charter and lastly today I
will set our national day is supposed to
be attained to celebrate and be happy
but unfortunately some rioters choose to
do all these all these sorts of criminal
damages arsons goon things are something
for the officer and various behavior
which encryption to a wire effects
almost demonstrating to the whole world
that we are supposed to be travel Hong
Kong is a safe city today is really
central me
different violent protests in more and
more districts
today is we have conducted its this
operations relating to the amendment of
the future fo the ordinance it is
already over 110 days already our
offices doing their job wholeheartedly
every day over 15 hours every day
committing themselves to protect the
city and protect the life and property
of the hawkmen citizen we are in a
typical moment but we will remain
steadfast and we will committed to our
duty to protect everyone in the society